ha thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen boy not
only am i celebrating my 50th birthday
but I also get to make the presentation
in the animated short subject category
that's got to be me of course
incidentally I thought you were dynamite
in Steamboat Willie
wait a minute distort I'm animated I'm
short I'm animated I'm a little wired as
a matter of fact
happy birthday making you look good for
50 you look great you know what we're
gonna get you for your birthday
two more fingers Thank You mr. Williams
you know this is Mickey's 50th birthday
too
yeah we all congratulate him he is
forever young and he has kept us young
the nominees this year for the animated
film short board are but those very
special John and faith Hubley and Gary
Trudeau producer Don addy I'm dawn Jimmy
the see James speaker Robert Grossman
and Frank Whittaker producer George
the winner is you know we buy our shoes
at the same place
the winner is sandcastle kohat Minh
500 now thank you very much well I think
I should tell you something and that is
that we have back in Canada an
extraordinary institution and that's
called the National Film Board of Canada
and through the National Film Board it's
been possible for many Canadian
filmmakers Americans and people from all
over the world to express themselves and
put their feelings on film expects
themselves culturally a pioneer in all
kinds of animation and film techniques
and I think I should be grateful for
them all because it was through them and
the National Film Board and all my
helpers that I've been able to make this
little film and I hope you can all see
it thank
now we come to live-action shorts the
direct descendants of are you growing
one into reelers one and two reelers
invented by Mack Sennett and devoted
almost exclusively to pratfalls and
custard pies but no longer the nominees
for the live action short film award are
the absent-minded waiter William eva
kuhn produces floating free Jerry butts
producing I'll find a way Beverly
Schaefer and Yuki Yoshida producers
notes on popular arts solve ass producer
I'll find a way
accepting the award for a while
evolution
the film I'll find a way is the story of
nine-year-old Nadia DeFranco who is
physically handicapped she and I hope
that everyone who sees the film and in
particular children will be sensitized
to the need and the dignity of the
physically handicapped people I would
like to thank the people of Canada who
support the National Film Board of
Canada and make it a very special and
unique place to make films thank you to
Kathleen Shannon my executive producer
and to the women's unit at the film
board and to all those who helped make
this film and thank you to my family and
my friends all of whom share this
excitement thank you
you